oh yeah i don't make any money on
youtube what do you mean
so i mean i can tell you like my
paycheck right now on youtube is under
what oh my god it's not a big deal it's
under 800 bucks let's talk about
dodgeball thunderdome
premiering 19th how do you feel like
this show
is different superior to other
superior of course yeah i feel like
you're going to say it's superior so i
was helping you um well it's uh it's
different because
it's not only is it the absolute force
but it's the element
of of dodging balls right so there's all
kinds of balls you have to dodge
we got little faults we got medium balls
and we have we have balls the size of
like
indiana jones balls that like kind of
did you just say balls a lot oh my god
an entire show is like
where there's obviously there's only so
many jokes you can make about balls
and blue balls and all that so it's like
it's like you have to find new ways to
be innovative
it's absolute forces but with a twist
where where the other competitors can
get back at each other and throw balls
at each other so it's like
two two games in one are there celebrity
guests
to be expected are you bringing in john
stamos
any friends of yours you smiled when i
said john stamos
yeah because john john would be just
really funny on the course good idea
and now that i have it i will i will
give him a call but
there's um this season this season i
don't know should i say yes even known
even though there aren't see well
there's just a lot
yeah this season even though there
aren't i'm gonna say yeah
stick around there's gonna be some crazy
guess
you know about season two yet or no no
no
yeah i won't know until we see how how
well this does
yeah and then i get a text saying man
you really you really messed it up for
discovery or i get a text saying hey
dude that was great thank you let's do
season two
go watch the show so i don't get fired
i have to talk to you about tick tock
because you're one of the creators to
get paid
how did that happen i i don't know i
feel like i've always just been pretty
close to tick tock and
we've always been talking about like i i
don't know i was
i hate to say this because it makes me
sound so lame but um
but i was one of the first fans of tic
tac i did a brand deal with them to
to plug the app and then as i was doing
that brandy i was like i was like really
like
messing around with the app and trying
to figure it out and then right when we
were done with that brandi i came back
to them like
three weeks later and i was like let's
do more please i'm so excited about
promoting this thing and they're like
well we're kind of already like taking
off and then that's when they became
like this
huge huge app and they didn't need any
help so i feel like i've been like
i've been communicating with them for
quite some time and it's really nice
because i
i don't make a dime on youtube so it's
nice that some videos
some videos are being what do you want
to make a dime on youtube
oh you don't know no oh yeah i don't
make any money on youtube
what do you mean like i don't get paid
for the the videos on my channel
why i didn't know that yeah they're all
demonetized and they all have uh they're
all copyrighted by uh
by labels so like every every time i use
a song
so i mean i can tell you like my
paycheck right now on youtube is under
what oh my god it's not a big deal it's
under 800 bucks which is which is
which is very low for to be able to
produce those videos because there's a
lot of things that i have to pay for
um but yeah it's like it's really low
it's it got cut after like
all the advertisers backed out
um and then they came back in and like
my my type of videos because i have
swearing and stuff
weren't really uh weren't really being
paid for as much so yeah i don't i don't
make money on there
can you talk to youtube or have you
talked to youtube about changing that
yeah i'm not like going see you later
youtube but um
even though it looks like it because i
haven't posted in months um but i
thought you haven't posted though
because of quarantine and you're like i
want to wait
no that's why it is because i just i i
don't want to post stuff from my house
uh people will find out how boring i am
and that's the last thing i want people
to know
but yeah now yeah we talk to you about
it it's just tough to do
because the labels are involved and my
my
the intro song i use that goes like
there's an intro song i use my videos
and goes
that song is copyrighted so like and so
even the two seconds of it every time i
use it
the label takes money from that so it
doesn't
it doesn't really matter what youtube
says it's just there's labels involved
and it's like such it's just such a pain
in the butt
my mind is blown yeah mine went mine was
two
two years ago when i found out all right
yeah
thank god for your brand deals thank god
for chipotle right
yeah i think that for chipotle and merch
so go buy merch
please watch the show and please watch
your tick tock
if yeah please watch my tic tacs do you
think tick tock will go away on
september 15th
what do you think is going to happen
with that no i think they're going to
figure it out
it's too crazy it's too huge of a
cultural impact for it to just like go
away
um that would really suck if it went
away and i don't even mean for me i mean
for
like all the there's so many younger
creators that are
actually putting out some really cool
stuff and they're really like
flexing their creative muscle on that
app and um
and that sucks that's like it's such a
cool place
to put like i was talking to somebody
and it's like it's so interesting how we
don't see
we don't see like the modern day seth
rogens or jonah hills
all the funny kids are focusing their
time on things like tick tock and that's
not a bad thing
but like why why spend nine months
writing something
when it's gonna take four years to
produce when you can just put it out
there and make people laugh right away
and i think tick tock has the ability to
do that and it would suck if they took
that away
if it does go away let's just play
devil's advocate how would that
affect you and almost your social media
strategy
i don't know i i'm always gonna figure
out a way to to post somewhere else or
i don't know i'm i'm really not tied
down to any certain social media
um i just like posting to post
for fun um so that would suck i i
genuinely i'm not just saying this to
like
sound like i care about others more than
i care about myself i it's gonna suck
more for other people that are like
finding their footing on that app i
don't think i'm gonna take it away it'll
be crazy
and if they do and we have another
interview i'm gonna look real done
well not to get into any specific
details but i do feel like you have
quite the
level-headed persona about you
you're just you never get into trouble
how do you stay out of
trouble you see some of these young
creators you know
i literally i'm just at home most of the
time now and i'm pretty
boring when i'm not the only time i can
get into trouble
is like when i'm filming and we're out
and about and
and we're just like in the moment doing
fun things and
we're speeding and i've such good
friends around me too that like if i'm
doing something that's like
not right my friends would be like yo
what the [ __ ] like they put me in check
and i think that's
that's the most important thing is to
have people around you
that that can check your ego and check
everything about you where
you're not getting out of not getting
out of hand yeah
um they have to do that at least once a
[Music]
day